مشاهدينا نكمل واياكم هذه التغطيه
لاحداث السودان اذا عمليات اجلاء متسارعه
من السودان دول عده ارسلت طائرات لاجلاء
رعاياها في اليوم التاسع من الاشتباكات
المتواصله بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
وفيما لم تفلح جهود الوساطه الداخليه
والخارجيه لحل الخلاف يترقب السودانيون
تصعيدا متواصل والصمخاوف من ازمات في
القطاع الصحي ونقص في المواد الغذائيه
ومياه الشرب
[موسيقى]
الناس كلها سكان هنا بتاع البحريه يعني
شبه كل سكان يعني
احنا لنا ثمانيه ايام بالليل في بدايه
الاحداث لم يعني لا توجد اننا ماء تماما
ولا يوجد عندنا كهرباء وكنا
في
اتهامات متبادله بين قائد الجيش السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف بحمد في
خلال لقائهما غير المباشر عبر العربيه
اتهم كل طرف الاخر ببدء الحرب وخرق الهدنه
والهجوم على منازل السكان والبعثات
الاجنبيه فلنتابع ما قاله الطرفان
البرهان وحماتي جنرالانى الى الحرب بعد ان
كان السودان قاب قوسين او ادنى من توقيع
اتفاق تاريخي العربيه جمعت البرهان وحماتي
على شاشتها في حوار غير مباشر بينهما في
مقابلتين خاصتين من بدا الحرب اليوم
موجودين في الغارات وتم الهجوم علينا من
قبل هذه المجموعات المتمرده
من يسيطر على العاصمه وما ابرز اماكن وجود
قوات كل طرف
[موسيقى]
نعم هنالك وجود لمجموعات كثيره جدا من هذه
القوات وسط الاحياء السكنيه
بالنسبه للسيطره بتاعتنا في الخرطوم فقط
الناتج المتبقيه لهم المهندسين
اين يوجد البرهان وحميتي انا موجود في
قياده القوات المسلحه ومبارحه ولن ابارحها
هذه هي مهنتي وهذا شرفي لن اخرج الا
محمولا على نعش
انا متزوج داخل الخرطوم موجود
بكل عميق انا موجود في كل
من خلق الهدنه
اعلنت اصلا ما حتى ابتدات لان
القوات الطرف الاخر غير مسيطر عليها وهي
منتشره في مناطق مختلفه من الاحياء
السكنيه
من اختار الحرب عوض السلام اليوم
نريد ان نخرج نخرج الى خارج دائره الدفاع
من يستهدف المستشفيات والبعثات الاجنبيه
اخرجت المواطنين في المنازل اخرجت
المستشفيات واحتلت المستشفيات
كيف ستنتهي المعركه
لم تعلم الى اي مدى هذه الحرب انا اقول ان
هذه الحرب ليس فيها كاسد
فيما يشهد مشاهدينا محيط القياده العامه
اشتباكات متقطعه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع قال ممثل السياسه الخارجيه
والامنيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيفورال انه
حث قائدي الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقلو اليوم على الوقوف او الوقف الفوري
الاطلاق النار واضاف ايضا عبر حسابه على
تويتر اضافه بوريل على انه اكد هاتفيا
للبرهان ودجل بضروره حمايه المدنيين وضمان
الاجلاء الامن لمواطني الاتحاد الاوروبي
مشاهدينا ساشير الى هذا العاجل الذي ورد
الان ونتابعه على الشاشه الاتحاد الاوروبي
يقول بانه اجلى البعثه الكامله اذا بعثت
الاتحاد الاوروبي اجليت بالكامل من
السودان وبامان اذا كان هذا التصحيح
بالتوازي مع عمليه الاجلاء التي بدات منذ
ساعات وطبعا هي ستستكمل بالساعات المقبله
لاجلاء جميع البعثات الدبلوماسيه وطبعا
الاجانب الموجودين على الاراضي
السوداء الى مطار جده ومن هناك طبعا يتم
اخراجهم او سفرهم الى بلادهم بامان بجهود
وتنسيق بين
بين يعني الجهات الرسميه السعوديه وطبعا
طرفي النزاع في السودان ما يحدث في
السودان لن يبقى داخل السودان سباعيه
افريقيه قد تتاثر بتفاقم النزاع اكثر
فخروج ذوي الانفجارات وقتال الشوارع عن
مساحه المليون وثمانمائه الف كيلو متر
مربع ليس مستبعدا طبعا جوله اولى من حرب
اهليه قد تمتد الى سبع دول يتشارك السودان
حدودا ملتهبه معها بالاستناد الى عاملين
مدى استمراريه النزاع ونتيجه هذا النزاع
فلنتابع التفاصيل في هذا التقرير
حقائب وموظبه وسرر محموله على الراس احد
مخاوف السباعيه المحيطه بالسودان وليس
اكبرها كوابيس تتسرب عبر السدود وانابيب
المياه وتتمل بعتاد حركات مسلحه عبر
الحدود التي باتت بيئه اكثر خصوبه للتمرد
اجلس الانذار التي تدق اقليميا ودوليا لا
تنحصر بكون السودان ثلث اكبر دوله في
افريقيا بل لانه يمتد عبر منطقه حيويه
جيوسياسيا غير مستقره وهشه ببعض اجزائها
مصر المتعطشه للمياه اكثر دوله عربيه
اكتظاظا بالسكان وتتشارك مع السودان
تاريخا من السياسه والتجاره والثقافه
ومياه النيل فضلا عن علاقات وثيقه بالجيش
واكثر من اربعه ملايين سودانيه على
اراضيها واي اضطراب بالعمق الاستراتيجي
لمصر من شانه عرقله الجهود المشتركه
للتوصل لل بشان سد النهضه التهديد المائي
ليس فقط ما تشكله اثيوبيا بطموحاتها
الكهرومائيه فالمناوشات على الحدود غير
منقطعه اصلا وقد يتسبب النزاع بعوده
التوتر بمنطقه الفجر الخصبه الحدوديه
المتنازع عليها
تشاد الجاره الغربيه الفقيره تحتضن بالاصل
نحو 400 الف نازح سوداني جراء صراعات
سابقه اضيف اليهم اكثر من عشرين الفا
مؤخرا القلق التشادينابع من مخاوف امتداد
الازمه لمناطق استقبلت اللاجئين ومعظمهم
من دارفور فتاريخ تشاد طويل مع ميليشيات
الجنجويد التي شكلت نواه قوات احمد تي
قلق مشابه يتكون غربا مرتزقه ومسلح
ميليشيات سودانيون عادوا الى بلادهم بعد
لعب دور نشط في الصراع الليبي هؤلاء على
معرفه جيده بالساحه الليبيه ومطاردتهم
داخليا قد ترميهم على الحدود مجددا اما
جنوب السودان الدوله التي استقلت حديثا
فمخاوفها تتمثل ببدء عرقله الروابط
اللوجستيه لتصريف انتاجها النفطي البالغ
170 الف برميلا يوميا عبء اقتصادي قد
تزيده سوءا عوده جماعيه لاكثر من 800 الف
لاجئ يستضيفهم السودان ازمه تتشاركها مع
اريتريا فمئه من مواطنيها قد يضطرون لحزم
امتعتهم من جديد
اعلن المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في
السودان خالد عمر يوسف ان النزاع الحالي
في السودان سيكون سببا في ضياع البلاد دون
استعادتها مؤكدا انها حرب لن ينتصر فيها
اي طرف ويوسف اشار ايضا الى ما اعتبرها
فرصه متاحه حاليا لايقاف الحرب وتشكيل
جبهه مدنيه لتجاوز الازمه الراهنه كما اكد
على اهميه اولويه اجتماع الاطراف العسكريه
والمدنيه على طاوله الحوار للتواصل الى حل
دعم
ينضم الينا من ابوظبي الفريق عثمان بوني
رئيس تحالف قوى الخلاص الوطني السوداني
استاذ عثمان يعني هناك اليوم تعويل كبير
على المبادرات الخارجيه اتحدث عن
الاقليميه وعن الامميه الدوليه الا انه
بالمقابل ايضا هناك تعويل على الدور
الداخلي لقوى التحالف الداخلي وللقوى
الوطنيه الداخليه الى اي مدى انتم قادرون
اليوم على يعني احداث نوع من الخرق على خط
هذه الازمه التي تعتبر جامده حتى الساعه
اولا نشكر قناه العربيه للاستضافه
وعبركم نحيي شعبنا الصامت في سودان العزه
والكرامه
في الحقيقه يعني اولا نحن نرى ان المجتمع
الدولي الان فقط هو يعني بيقدم الشد
والاستنكار فقط ولكن يعني لم يتقدم
بمبادرات رسميه حتى اللحظه
اما في الداخل هنالك مبادره الان من
الاليه الوطنيه لدعم التحول الديمقراطي
وهي يعني قوه وطنيه ليست بل هو السياسيه
عندهم العاب مبادره نحن في قوى التحالف
الخلاصه الوطني الان لدينا مبادره وان شاء
الله هذه المبادره سوف تطرح خلال اليومين
القادمين عبر منصه الاتحاد الافريقي
باعتبار الاجتهاد الافريقي هي المنظمه
الدوليه المنظ بها حل مشاكل القاره
الافريقيه
وايضا الاتحاد الافريقي بما لديهم من
معرفه تامه بالوضع السياسي الراهن في
السودان منذ بدايه هذه الازمه يعني كل
التقارير الغربيه كانت تتحدث عن النظره
الغربيه الى الازمه السياسيه داخل السودان
بانها المنظار الاول هو حاله اللاستقرار
الذي ستؤدي اليها الازمه الداخليه
والانقسام الداخلي والاقتتال الداخلي
والمنظار الاخر هو الخوف من موجه النزوح
الكبيره التي ستتجه نحو الدول الاوروبيه
تحديدا اليوم يعني المنظرين بدا يتحقق بظل
استمرار النزاع كيف ممكن ان يؤثره على
جهود اكبر للجانب الغربي لحاسه طرفي
النزاع على الذهاب الى طاوله الحوار نحن
بالحقيقه من اول سؤال جميل جدا نحن الان
وليو على راسهم المتحده
وللاسف الشديد يعني هذا النزاع نحن الان
نحمل المجتمع الدولي لانه هو الاكثر لهذا
الاتفاق وهو الدعم يعني مجموعه صغيره جدا
جدا في الحريه والتغيير
المرحله الانتقاليه وعزل من عزل المجموعه
الاساس المؤسسه الحريه والتغيير
التي يعني تم التوقيع عليها في 2019
يعني تم وضع الوثيقه الدستوريه في 2019
هذه المجموعه الان التي تسمى نفسها مجموعه
الاطار هم الان سبب هذه الازمه هم سبب هذه
المشاكل هم يعني وجدوا الارضيه الصلبه
ووجدوا انه يعني السند من السيد فوركر هو
ممثل الامين العام الخرطوم ونحن بالحقيقه
يعني من هذا المنطلق يعني نحن الان نخاطب
السيد الامين العام
للاولى المتحده بسحب الممثل بتاعه في
الخرطوم او استبداله لانه هذا الرجل هو
كان سبب المشاكل في السودان وهو كان سبب
يعني هذه الازمات الموجوده نحن الان اذا
مثلا المجتمع الدول الان هو عايز يساعد في
حل هذه المشاكل واضح اذا كبرنا المجتمع
الدولي ما يساعد نحن مستعدين على الحل
يعني ايضا هناك سوداني هناك
من منظار الحل السوداني السوداني هناك
ايضا تحميل يعني مسؤوليه كبيره لقوى
المعارضه وقوى الاطار وكل المجتمع المدني
الذي قاد يعني فتره الثوره ما بعد الثوره
بان الانقسام الكبير داخل هذه القوى ايضا
ادى الى ما وصلت اليه الحال في البلاد
والى عرقله الحل والانتقال السلمي للسلطه
ومن هنا يعني ياتي ايضا التخبط الغربي
بالتعاطي مع الملف السوداني الداخلي
[موسيقى]
عاده العمل بالوثيقه الدستوريه التي توافق
عليها كل الشعب السوداني وتم التوقيع
عليها في في 2019 وتم العمل بها في الفتره
الاولى اللي هي حكومه السيد حمدوك
اليوم يعني
بموازاه هذه الصوره هناك تهديد بتمزيق
المجتمع السوداني اذا ما ذهبنا الى الى حل
داخلي قبل ان يكون خارجي ممكن ان يكون على
المثال الليبي او على امثله اخرى موجوده
داخل المنطقه نتحدث عن التقسيم القبلي
الذي هو اصلا موجود داخل السودان وايضا عن
مهددات الامن والاستقرار الداخلي السلاح
المتفلت وغيره التي كان هناك سعي لضب
ضابطه
وللملمت هذا الملف من الداخل السوداني الى
اي مدى هناك خطر على واقع المجتمع
السوداني بالفتره المقبله
الشعب السوداني شديد
اي يعني اي نزاعات وكما تعلمين يعني هنالك
كانت في حرب عن الدروس في جنوب السودان
هذه الحرب امتدت عن العشرات السنين ولم
يحصل انه يعني اي زعزع او اي يعني
انقسامات في المكون المكون الغبري في
السودان بل الان الان يعني في تماسك في
الجبهه الداخليه السودانيه والان كل الشعب
السوداني الان متماثل وكل الشعب السوداني
الان يقف مع مع وحده الدوله السودانيه نحن
الان نبغي في على الحياه درسنا انه يعني
الدعم القوات المسلحه او تعمل يعني
الدوله السودانيه ونحن كجهمه مطلبيه تجاهه
يعني نمثل الهامشه السوداني العريض ومطالب
الشعب السوداني فبالتالي هذا الشعب
الاواعي وان شاء الله يعني سوف تمر هذه
الازمه وسوف تنجلي ولكن نحن نرى ان
المفروض يعني كل الدول الان
نناشد الدول الصديقه وخاصه الدول العربيه
والدول الشقيقه انه يعني
يعني يحصل انه مبادره عبر جامعه الدول
العربيه
لانه هي الاطار او البيت العربي الممكن
يعني لا تقدر ترجع له وهي واحد وكلماته
عبرهم ابقى معنا لو سمحت استاذ عثمان
مشاهدينا
سنعرض واياكم او نستعرض واياكم هذه الصور
التي نشرها الجيش السوداني وهي مقطع فيديو
قال انه يظهر استلام قوات الدعم السريع او
استسلام قوات الدعم السريع في الفشقه
الصغرى فلنتابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر مشاهدينا فقط
للتوضيح بان هذا الاستسلام هو حصل قبل
ايام والفيديو نشره الجيش السوداني يعني
بساعات الماضيه
العشر الاواخر من رمضان الحمد لله باليوم
الخامس والعشرين من رمضان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تبارك الله العملياتي
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا من القاهره اللواء
معتصم العجب المحلل العسكري وعضو تجمع
قدامى المحاربين السودانيين استاذ يعني
اليوم خارطه وتوزيع القوى على الارض تختلف
من منطقه الى اخرى ولكن نتحدث عن خارطه
توزيع عسكري معقده نوعا ما وهي ستطيل امد
النزاع بالفتره المقبله هذه الخارطه مع ما
تمثله من ضغط على المجتمع السوداني وهجره
جماعيه نحو القاره الاوروبيه تحديدا اتحدث
هنا عن منفذين منفذ عبر عبر ليبيا
والمتوسط الى بريطانيا والى
ايطاليا والمنفذ الاخر عبر المغرب الى
فرنسا ما يحصل هناك على هذه الحدود كيف
يمكن ان يؤثر على حركه الدول الغربيه تجاه
الملف السودان
اكيد يعني اكيد
الهجره الغير الشرعيه
لها يعني لها واضح اني لا تاثيرات سلبيه
كبيره جدا على
الامن في في في اوروبا من اليونان وحتى
انجلترا يعني الغاره باكمله
اللي هو الطريق بتاع الهجره الشرعيه من
ايطاليا لفرنسا من فرنسا لانجلترا
لمرونه القوانين في انجلترا نحو اللجوء
كده
طبعا بالاونه الاخيره يعني
من وجهه نظري انه في في في يعني الناس دي
بتهاجر لاوروبا في
ضيق في
الاضطرابات موجوده في في عدد كبير جدا
افريقيه
ولما تزيد كمان السودان اللي هو كان اساسا
بيستقبل يعني احنا كنا بنستقبل اللاجئين
من
اثيوبيا او من جنوب السودان عدد كبير جدا
حتبقى مشكله يعني احنا كنا بنستقبل او
فيهم اعداد بسيطه يعني بسيطه جدا هي اللي
بتهاجر
عبر ليبيا يعني نسبيا بالنسبه للعدد
لكن بالنسبه للتضيف عليهم كمان دوله تانيه
تضيف عليهم 40 مليون
يضافوا
للعدد ده ونتيجه برضو للحروب اللي عندنا
الحروب كانت الاهليه الموجوده سواء كانت
في جنوب السودان نعم يعني عن الهجره من
دارفور من كردفان وايضا من جنوب
كل ما اقتربت دول وبعد هيك بالذات دوله
عندها خمسه دول يعني
دول دوله مفتوحه على دول الجوار استاذ
حضرت اللواء يعني اليوم ايضا من المعروف
بان الاثر البعيد وحتى القريب لكل
النزاعات التي حصلت بالسودان
هو عسكره المجتمعات خصوصا بمناطق المحاذيه
لمناطق النزاع اليوم نتحدث عن احتماليه
يعني اطاله امد هذا هذه المواجهه بقلب
العاصمه بقلب السودان عسكره المجتمع
السوداني ماذا تعني قبل ان استمع الى
جوابك اسمح لي ان اتابع الى ان الجيش
السوداني يعلن عبر التلفزيون الرسمي
السيطره الكامله على مدينه الاوبيض
اصبحت مدينه الاوبيض الان امنه سالمه
هانئه مطمئنه ندعو جميع المواطنين لفتح
الاسواق ومزاوله اعمالهم من صباح الغد
اصبحت المدينه امنه مطمئنه ونقول لهم
ونبشرهم اذا مشاهدينا تبعنا هذا الفيديو
للجيش السوداني يعلن فيه السيطره على
مدينه الاوبيض وهي احدى المناطق
الاستراتيجيه الى جانب مروي التي اعلن
سابقا ايضا السيطره عليها واليوم النزاع
يدور حول المنطقه الثالثه التي تعتبر
استراتيجيه وهو محيط القياده العامه
والقياده العامه بداخل الخرطوم اعود اليك
الى ضيف
كنا نسال عن
المزلت مع استاذ معتصم
نعم كنت اسال عن عسكره الداخل السوداني
ماذا تعني على الواقع السوداني على دول
المنطقه والى اي مدى ممكن ان تزيد يعني من
خطورتها كل ما طال امد النزاع
ماذا تقصدين بعسكره يعني عندما نتحدث عن
نزاع
نظام حكمي عسكري ولا
الشعب عسكره الشعب نفسه وهي طبعا هي الخطر
على المجتمع
طبعا اكيد يعني اكيد يعني في في بلد ما
زالت فيها
العصبيه الغبليه موجوده ما ننكرها
مجرد ما تعسكرت فيها زي ما حصل في في في
دارفور
دارفور من ائمن المناطق كانت في في
السودان
يعني انا مشيت دارفوردي سنه 67 ولا 66 ما
فيش ما بتشوف عسكري حتى بتاع الشرطه ما
محتاج
في اي حته تنوم في في اي حته في الخلاء
برا المدن يعني هو القور الكبيره
بلد كانت امنه جدا
لكن بطبيعه التكوين بتاع السودان ما زالت
القبيله موجوده يعني ما في يعني مثلا بلاد
في اوروبا
او في كثير من الدول ما زالت العصبيه
القبليه موجوده
والقبليه الساهل انك تحوله يعني تحول
العصبيه
نعم موضوع القبليه هو موضوع متجذع داخل
المجتمع
ارفعي صوتك شويه كنت اقول لك خصوصا ان
القبليه هو موضوع متجذر بالداخل السوداني
وله يعني بعدين بعد على مستوى الانتماء
الفردي وبعد اخر على مستوى الانتماء
الوطني ككل لن ادخل يعني بهذا التفصيل
ساعود الى موضوع العسكر
ما قلت لك العصبيه تذوب في السودان يعني
احنا يعني الواحد كبير وعاصر المرحله
بتاعت القبليه الاولى اللي هي كانت في
الخمسينات وتغير بعد شويه ابتدت العصبيه
دي تقل تقل يعني في الستينات وفي
السبعينات وفي الحد الثمانينات نهايه
الثمانينات ابتدت العصبيه دي لاسباب
سياسيه لاسباب سياسيه
بعثوا بعثوا القبليه تاني اللي هو النظام
النظام المخلوع البشير لاغراض سياسيه يعني
بعثت هذه القبليه في السودان بعد ما ابتدت
تتلاشى يعني ابتدت تتلاشى فعليا في المدن
يعني احنا زمان كان نسمع
القصه دي للاجيال البعدنه ما سمعوها حتى
فالناس السحرت مع بعض الناس يتجاورت مع
بعض
يعني ابتدت
زي ما بتتراجع العصبيه القبليه او
الانتماء للقبيله ابتدى يتراجع تم ثاني
بعث من النظام
يعني لا لنطوي هذه النقطه السياسيه على
اساس انه هي بدات بالعام 1932 نعم انخفضت
ثم عادت خلال حكم البشير والحرب الاهليه
يعني لنقطع هذا التفصيل اليوم ما يحصل
داخل المجتمع السوداني اذا ما لم يكن هناك
حل سريع كيف يمكن ان يؤثر على مستقبل
السوداء
ممكن تؤثر في مناطق في السودان
منادره الوعي فيها
شويه متدينة يعني لاظلت التعليم للاهمال
لكده يعني مش مش بسبب فما زالت موجوده
في انحاء كثيره لكن في في نواحي برضو
كبيره من السودان ومؤثره
يعني
عسكرته او غير عسكريه طبعا اكيد يعني في
ناس العصبيه منتنه يعني اسمح لي ابقى معي
لو سمحت ساعود ساعود اليك خلال هذه
التغطيه اللواء معتصم ايضا مشاهدينا يعني
بسيااق اخر اجلت حكومات اجنبيه دبلوماسيين
وموظفين اخرين محاصرين في السودان في
الوقت الذي يشتبك فيها القاده العسكريون
متنافسون لليوم التاسع بدون اي مؤشر على
تهدئه قريبه
لم يصمت الرصاص في السودان في هدن تم
الاتفاق عليها ما دفع الدول للبدء بعمليات
اجلاء رعاياها تحت النار تصدرت السعوديه
الدول التي اجلت رعاياها ورعاي دول اخرى
باول عمليه اجلاء لمدنيين حيث نقلت القوات
البحريه السعوديه اكثر من 150 شخصا من
السعوديين ورعاي دول اخرى من بورسودان الى
جده عبر البحر الاحمر
ووسطى تبادل الجيش وقوات حملت الاتهامات
بشان اطلاق النار اثناء عمليه اجلاء رعايه
فرنسيين كان احدها هؤلاء الرعايه قد اصيب
ولفتت الخارجيه الفرنسيه الى ان اجلاء
رعاياها يشمل ايضا مواطنين اوروبيين ودول
حليفه بدورها بدات بريطانيا والمانيا
واسبانيا في اجلاء رعاياها كما ارسلت
اليونان طائرات وقوات خاصه الى مصر
استعدادا لاجلاء 120 يونانيا وقبرصيا من
الخر كذلك فعلت هولندا بارسال طائرتين
تابعتين للسلاح الجو وطائره مدنيه الى
الاردن استباقا لمهمه انقاذ محتمله فيما
اوفدت ايطاليا طائرات عسكريه الى دوله
جيبوتي استعدادا لاجلاء 140 من رعاياها في
السودان كما حدث كل من الاردن ولبنان حدوه
تلك الدول
وارسلت طائرات تقل رعاياها بالاضافه الى
رعايه عرب واجانب كما اعلن الاردن على
لسان جيشه فيما بدا الرئيس الامريكي
مرتاحا لاجلاء 70 شخصا هم موظفوا سفره
الامريكيه في الخرطوم الى اثيوبيا
وبخلاف الرعب الذي يحرم حول عمليات
الاجلاء المهدده باشتعال القتال في اي وقت
فهناك تعقيدات اخرى منها شلل المطار
الرئيسي اضافه الى ايقاف تشغيل المطارات
الاخرى في انحاء السودان حنان المصري
العربيه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من ابو ظبي الفريق
عثمان بوني رئيس تحالف قوى الخلاص الوطني
السوداني استاذ عثمان سابدا من النقطه
التي كنا نتحدث عنها وهي موضوع الاجلاء
طبعا يعني الاجلاء يستكمل بهذه الساعات
وبالساعات المقبله هنا ينظر يعني الكثير
من المراقبين الى عمليات الاجلاء التي تتم
بسرعه وايضا يعني بشكل كبير لكل الرعايه
هناك على انها دليل على فشل الهدنه دليل
على فشل الحل السلمي السياسي حتى الساعه
وايضا دليل على استمرار وحرب طويله الامد
بين الطرفين كيف تنظرون لهذا الموضوع
وايضا كيف تنظرون الى خطر دخول البلاد
بحرب طويله الامد
وايضا ممكن دخول اطراف دوليه على خط
النزاع
نعم هو بالحقيقه يمكن يعني الان تمت يعني
خروقات عده خروقات لوقت اطلاق النار وايضا
يعني هنالك هناك تبادل الاتهامات والانكار
من الاعتداءات المتكرره بين الجيش وبين
الدعم السريع
ويمكن من هذا المنطلق نحن الان برضو من
ضمن المبادره بتاعتنا تقدمنا يعني انه
طرحنا وضع اليه
للمراقبه والمتابعه لوقف اطلاق النار
وتامين المسارات العامله للمواطنين وايضا
عوده الخدمات الاساسيه للمواطنين
للسؤال الكهرباء او المياه او المستشفيات
وغيره
فبالحقيقه يمكن الان يعني
الوضع الحاصل في السودان شويه يعني لابد
ان يكون هنالك وجود غابه على الارض
الان الحربي تحولت حرب المدن وداخل
الاحياء وداخل المتفاعلات السكنيه
فبالتالي ليس يعني يعني الوجود
العسكري داخل المدن هو الان يسبب في
الزعزعه يعني والخوف والهلع بين المواطنين
فلابد ان تكون هنالك اليه هي للتقييم
وللمتابعه ولرفع التقريره للجهات المختصه
وتكون هي في جهه يعني تحت اشراف جهه
محايده دوليه
حاله لا استقرار داخلي سياسي امني على كل
المستويات ستؤدي الى يعني تفاقم ومزيد من
الصراعات ذات الابعاد القبليه الاثنيه
والجهويه حتى الى اي مدى ممكن ان تتفاقم
كلما طال امد هذه الازمه
هو بالحقيقه يمكن يعني الان الجبهه يعني
الجبهه الداخليه الان يعني كما ذكرنا ما
زالت متماسكه ولكن يعني ما افتكر انه مثلا
ممكن بعد شويتين يعني لو الحرب يعني ممكن
تتحول الى حرب اهليه لانه الشعب السوداني
يختلف يمكن يعني من الشعوب وايضا الموقع
الجغرافي للسوداني يختلف فبالتالي نحن
الان
نناشد انه يعني
طرفين
بتحكيم صوت العقل والجلوس الى معده
المفاوضات والناس تقدر تتحاور لانه اي حرب
في العالم في نهايته هي راح تكون مائده
المفاوضات يعني اي حرب لن تنتهي في
الميدان ولكن يعني هي بتنتهي في معده
المفاوضات فعليه نحن تجنيب البلاد وتجنيب
الايباد لانه الطرفين هم الان صراعوا يعني
صراع سلطه وليس صراع ايدولوجيا او
نقاط قوه واوراق قوه قبل الجلوس الى طاوله
المفاوضات شكرا لك من ابو ظبي الفريق
عثمان باونين رئيس تحالف قوى الخلاص
الوطني السوداني على هذه المداخله
على صعيد الجهود الدوليه والاقليميه لوقف
التصعيد في السودان طلقه وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه اتصالا من نظيره البريطاني بحث
خلاله التطورات المتسارعه في السودان
واوضاع الاجانب على قانون هناك حيث اكد
الطرفان على اهميه وقف التصعيد بالسودان
وحمايه مدنيين وضروره توفير ممرات امنه
للراغبين بمغادره السودان
كما بحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان هاتفيا مع رئيس الوزراء
القطري ووزير الخارجيه محمد بن عبد الرحمن
بن جاسم الثاني جهود وقف التصعيد العسكري
في السودان وناقش الوزيران ايضا جهود
توفير الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين
السودانيين وتهدئه توتر المتصاعد في
العديد من المواقع الحيويه داخل السودان
في الكويت عاد اليوم 25
مواطنا قادمين من مطار جده الدولي في
السعوديه وذلك في اطار الخطه الطارئه التي
نفذتها وزاره الخارجيه الكويتيه لاجلاء
المواطنين العالقين جراء الاشتباكات
المسلحه والتطورات الامنيه في السودان
[موسيقى]
افادت مصادر العربيه باعطاء مصر الضوء
الاخضر لبدء عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
حيث قالت المصادر ان الجيش المصري ينسق مع
نظيره السوداني لبدء العمليات كما اشارت
مصادر العربيه من الجيش السوداني سيتولى
مرافقه قوافل المصريين حتى المعابر
الحدوديه وانا السودان زود مصر بتفاصيل
الممرات الامنه لنقل المصريين لاماكن
الاجلاء هذا وكانت مصر نشرت قوات امنيه
على معابرها الحدوديه مع السودان لتامين
عمليه الاجلاء
قالت مشاهدينا وزاره الخارجيه الاثيوبيه
انما يحدث في السودان شان داخلي وانا
اثيوبيا مستعده للوساطه اذا طلب من ذلك
واضافت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه
تسعى لتهدئه الاوضاع في السودان بعيدا عن
التقارير الوهميه مشيره الى انه لا صحه
للتقارير التي تتحدث عن تدخل لاثيوبيا في
السودان هذا وشددت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه على
انها تراقب عن كثب وضع الجاليه الاثيوبيه
الموجوده في السودان
مشاهدينا باخر العواجل حول عمليه جلاء
التي تحصل من الاراضي الاثيوبيه الى
الاراضي المصريه الخارجيه المصريه تعلن عن
او الاراضي السودانيه عفوا تعلن عن اجلاء
436 مواطنا من السودان برا اذا كنا تحدثنا
عن معبرين بالمناطق العاديه وثلاثه الى
اربع معابر بالمناطق مناطق النزاع اتفق
عليها الجانب المصري والجانب الاثيوبي
السوداني عفوا الجيش السوداني لنقل
المصريين الموجودين داخل السودان
نتابع مشاهدينا هذه الصور حول عمليه اجلاء
المصريين من الاراضي السودانيه هذه الصور
المباشره من الخرطوم
اذا مشاهدينا هي صور مباشره للتصحيح من
الخرطوم
سبعنا قبل قليل اصوات اشتباكات عادت طبعا
بعد الهدنه التي كانت متقطعه نوعا ما
والتي من المتوقع بعد انتهاء ان يكون هناك
احتدام للمعارك والاشتباكات بين الطرفين
ساستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي في حال كان هناك
اي اشتباك واعود
اذا على ما يبدو ان يعني الاشتباكات
المتقطعه
يتم يعني خرق هذا الهدوء الذي نسمعه من
وقت الى اخر باشتباكات بين الطرفين طبعا
العين على الساعات المقبله بعد اتمام بعض
عمليات الاجلاء الاساسيه من السودان والتي
تتم بالتنسيق بين الجانب السعودي والجانب
السوداني عبر اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
والسعوديين والعرب الى جده ومن هناك يتم
طبعا
اعاده اجلاء الاجانب الى دولهم والعرب الى
دولهم طبعا الجانب المصري يقوم بعمليه
الاجلاء برا تابعنا قبل قليل حوالي 500
مصري وصلوا عبر البر من السودان الى
الداخل المصري
صرح وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان للعربيه بان
جنوب السودان قامت باستقبال اقصى اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف لاجئ من السودان ومستعده
لاستقبال المزيد من هؤلاء كما قال ان رئيس
جنوب السودان اجرى مكالمه هاتفيه مع
الرئيس المصري لحث البرهان على المواقع
لوقف اطلاق النار
لقد قمنا باستقبال مجموعه من السودانيين
لسنوات عده وامنا ما ولهم ونحن سعيدون
لهذا ولدينا اكثر من ثلاثه الاف لاجئ من
السودان يعيشون بكرامه في جنوب السودان
ونحن مستعدون لاستقبال المزيد منهم ان
رئيسنا اجرى مكالمه هاتفيه مع الرئيس
المصري وتطرق للوضع الحالي وكيف يمكنهما
العمل على حث البرهان لوقف اطلاق النار
والعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات وذلك لوقف
الخلافات بين الطرفين المتحاربين
بالعوده الى عمليات الاجلاء المتواصله
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن اجراء
100 شخص من السودان على ان يتبعهم 100
اخرين فيما كشفت مصادر ومصدرا فرنسيان
للعربيه ان فرنسا ستجلي رعاياها بطائرتين
عبر مطار يبعد 20 كم عن الخرطوم مؤكده ان
طائرتين نقل الرعايه الفرنسيين ستتجهان
الى جيبوتي
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من باريس حسين قنيبر
مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا حسين سابدا عن
موضوع اجلاء الفرنسيين الى فرنسا ماذا في
التفاصيل لو سمحت
بيان مصادر عن وزارتي الخارجيه والدفاع
قبل قليل جاء فيه انه بطلب من رئيس
الجمهوريه وفي مواجهه التدهور السريع
للوضع في السودان جرى اجلاء عدد من
الرعايه الفرنسيه ومن جنسيات اخرى تابعه
لدول طلبت منا المساعده فساعدناها اذا
فرنسيون
وحاملوه بل حمله جنسيات اخرى خصوصا
اوروبيه جرى اجلؤهم من السودان الى جيبوتي
بعد ظهر اليوم علامات طائره تابعه لسلاح
الجو الفرنسي عددهم يبلغ حوالى المئه
وصلوا الى جيبوتي قبل حوالي ساعتين ونصف
الساعه من الان ستكون هناك طائرات اخرى
تحمل اعدادا اضافيه من الفرنسيين
والاوروبيين وجاء في بيان الخارجيه
الفرنسيه ان السفاره الفرنسيه في جيبوتي
والعسكريون الفرنسيون المتواجدون في هذا
البلد بالتنسيق مع مركز الازمات والدعم في
و الخارجيه هنا في باريس يقومون بمتابعه
عمليات الاجلاء وجه بيان الخارجيه
الفرنسيه الليالي شكرا خاصه الى سلطات
جيبوتي على مساعدتها الحاسمه التي جعلت
عمليه الاجلاء ممكنه كما اشار هذا البيان
الى ان كل اجهزه الدوله الفرنسيه ستبقى
مستنفره للقيام بعمليات اجلاء جديده عندما
يكون ذلك ممكنا كما شكر البيان الاطراف
السودانيه التي تسهل عمليه الاجلاء من
السودان يفترض ان تصل طائره ثانيه الى
الجيبوتي الليله ولكن عمليات وصول الذين
يسار الى اجلائهم وصولهم الى باريس ليس
واضحا بعد ربما يكون ذلك في الساعات
الاولى من يوم غد ليال
حسين يعني سنعود خلال هذه التغطيه لمتابعه
التطورات حول نقل الرعايه من هناك ولكن
هناك نقطه مهمه بدء اثارتها بالداخل
الاعلامي الفرنسي هو موضوع المهاجرين يعني
بالقبل كانت كل التقارير تتحدث عن ان
المغرب كانت الوجهه الاولى للمهاجرين
السودانيين بالانتقال الى فرنسا اليوم
هناك تخوف من عوده موجات النزوح الى
الداخل الفرنسي بالاضافه طبعا الى دول
اخرى هل يعني بدا الحديث عن اي تدابير
جديده او اضافيه
لكي لا تكون فرنسا هي الوجهه
فرنسا بالمناسبه الليالي تستعدوا لمناقشه
مشروع قانون جديد خاص بالهجره يشدد
الاجراءات التي يجب ان تحول دون وصول
اعداد كبيره من المهاجرين مهما كانت
جنسيتهم الى الاراضي الفرنسيه وطبعا
الاتصالات التي تجريها فرنسا مع عده اطراف
اوروبيه ودوليه وعربيه وافريقيه تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار النقطه التي اتحدثت عنها طبعا
الاتصالات الفرنسيه بهذه الاطراف تتناول
عده نقاط من بينها هذه النقطه تحديدا
الاتصالات الفرنسيه كانت تكثفت خلال
الساعات والايام القليله الماضيه هي شملت
كلا من السعوديه ومصر والامارات والامين
العام للامم المتحده ووزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه ووزير الخارجيه الامريكي كل
هؤلاء اتصلت بهم وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
كاترين كما علمنا اعود الى عمليات الاجلاء
علمنا ان من الجنسيات المتواجده على
الطائره التي اقلت الذين جرى اجلائهم من
السودان اليوم هناك مواطنون اوروبيون من
بلجيكا من المانيا من سويسرا حتى ان
الطاقم الدبلوماسي التابعه لبعثت الاتحاد
الاوروبي في السودان هو من بين الذين جرى
اجلائهم على ما طائره تابعه لسلاح الجو
الفرنسي هناك ايضا مواطنون من المغرب ومن
مصر والنيجر من بين الذين جرى اجلائهم
ليالان حسين
قبل هل
هناك عطيات حول من ما زالوا موجودين داخل
السودان هل هناك اي وجود يعني لبعثات
اجنبيه ممكن ان يتحرك سلاح الجو بساعات
المقبله لنقلهم
طبعا فرنسا تقول ان تنسيقها مستمر مع
شركائها ومع حلفائها ومع الاطراف
السودانيه من خلال سفاره فرنسا في الخرطوم
ومن خلال مركز الازمات والدعم التابع
لوزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كما ان الرئيس
الفرنسي اجرى اتصالات بالسلطات في جيبوتي
وفي اثيوبيا كما ان هناك دولا كانت ترفض
فتح المجال الجوي وبعد اتصالات للرئيس
ماكرون عادت وفتحت المجال الجوي اتصل
الرئيس ووزيره الخارجيه كولونا بكل من عبد
الفتاح البرهان وحميدتي طالبينا اليهما
العمل على ضمان امن الفرنسيين والاوروبيين
الذين يسار الى اجلائهم من السودان ليال
شكرا لك حسين قنيبر مدير مكتب العربيه في
فرنسا على هذه المعطيات التي وفيتنا بها
في اثناء مشاهدينا صرحت وزاره الدفاع
والخارجيه الالمانيتان ان برلين بدات
باجلاء رعاياها من السودان في ظل استمرار
المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع كما اوضحت الوزاره عبر منصه تويتر
ان الهدف هو نقل اكبر عدد من الرعايه
الالمان من الخرطوم ضمن الامكانات وستساعد
في نقل رعايه دول اخرى من الاتحاد
الاوروبي
عمليه اجلاء الاجانب من السودان
السعوديه اجلت 91 مواطنا وسته وستين شخصا
من دول اخرى الى جده دفعه جديده مرتقبه
وصولها خلال ساعات
بريطانيا استكملت اجلاء موظفيها
الدبلوماسيين وعائلاتهم
المانيا طائره عسكريه هبطت في الخرطوم
لاجلاء رعاياها
فرنسا اجلت مئه شخص من السودان بطائرتين
من مطار قرب الخرطوم على ان يتبعهم 100
اخرون
الاردن ارسل اربع طائرات الى السودان
لاجلاء رعايه اردنيين وعرب وموظفين في
منظمات اغاثيه
مصر بدات باجلاء عشره الاف مصري عبر عمليه
محكمه وامنه ومنظمه
الولايه المتحده اجلت موظفي سفارتها
وعائلتهم ودبلوماسيين من دول اخرى
روسيا 140 روسيا من اصل 300 في السودان
يرغبون بالرحيل وهناك خطه لاجلائهم
تعمل كل من كوريا الجنوبيه والسويد
وهولندا وايطاليا لاجلاء مواطنها
اعلن وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه عن اغلاق
السفاره البريطانيه في الخرطوم مؤقتا
مؤكدا ان سلامه البريطانيين في السودان
تشكل اولويه قصوى بالنسبه له
لقد اتخذنا قرارا باغلاق السفاره
البريطانيه في الخرطوم مؤقتا واجلاء
الدبلوماسيين البريطانيين وعائلاتهم ونقل
وظائفنا الدبلوماسيه الى موقع دبلوماسي
قريب ونواصل العمل بشكل مباشر من خلال
شركائنا الدوليين للدعوه الى وقف اطلاق
النار ووضع حد لهذا العنف تبقى سلامه
حمايه الرعايه البريطانيه في السودان
اولويه قصوى بالنسبه لنا وسنقوم بهذا
الواجب من خلال سفاراتنا الموجوده في
المنطقه بالتنسيق الوثيق مع اصدقائنا
وشركائنا الدوليين
اكد وزير الدفاع البريطانيه ان عمليه
اجلاء الموظفين دبلوماسيين البريطانيين
وعائلاتهم تمت بنجاح مشيرا الى انه شارك
في عمليه الاجلاء اكثر من 1100 شخص
الليله الماضيه اجرى الجيش البريطاني
عمليه اجلاء للموظفين الدبلوماسيين
البريطانيين وعائلاتهم من الخرطومه
باستخدام عناصر من اللواء السادس عشر هجوم
جوي وسلاح الجو الملكي ومشات البحريه
الملكيه ساهم اكثر من 1200 شخص في هذه
العمليه المحفوفه بالمخاطر لكننا مع ذلك
تمكنا من استخدام طائرات سيمي 130 وايه
400 للدخول وجمع دبلوماسيين والمقيمين
معهم والطيران الى بر الامان
مشاهدينا ساتابع واياكم هذا الفيديو ومقطع
فيديو لسيطره الجيش السوداني على معسكر
للدعم السريع في ام درمان فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا تابعنا واياكم هذا الفيديو
الذي نشره الجيش السوداني ويظهر سيطره
الجيش على معسكر لقوات الدعم السريع في
منطقه ام درمان بالعوده الى موضوع الاجلاء
اجلاء الطواقم والبعثات الدبلوماسيه
الغربيه ينضم الينا من لندن ومراسل
العربيه مصطفى يعني عن كم نتحدث العدد
التنسيق الذي يتم بين السلطات البريطانيه
الفرنسيه الايطاليه الامريكيه وغيرها مع
دول المنطقه
حقيقه لم يتم الكشف عن العدد الذي تم
اجزاؤه من موظفي السفاره في الخرطوم الى
جانب افراد عائلاتهم لكن بحسب وزير الدفاع
عن العمليه كانت معقده للغايه ان السفاره
البريطانيه تقع بين
مقري الطرفين
المتنحرين في العاصمه الخرطوم وتم نقل
هؤلاء البريطانيين على متن طائرتين
عسكريتين الى قبرصله بها قاعده عسكريه
بريطانيه ضخمه ووزير ورئيس الوزراء
في في تغريده قال بان يعني العمليه كانت
سريعه ومعقده وصعبه للغايه وشكر ايضا
الحلفاء وخاصه الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
خلال هذه العمليه وهذا يشير بان هناك
تنسيق كبير على اعلى المستويات بين بين
مختلف
لاجلاء رعاياها من من السودان التي
شهدناها يعني
الصراع لا يزال لا يزال مستمر بالرغم من
ان المساعي الدوليه بما فيها مطالب مطالب
بريطانيا بوقف الاقتتال والعوده الى
المفاوضات لان المفوضات التي
ستؤدي الى السلام وليس الحرب مثل ما شهدنا
في الايام القليله الماضيه هذا من جانب من
جانب الثاني ان
البريطانيون المقيمون في السودان يعني لا
يزالون هناك لم نعرف العدد الحقيقي لهؤلاء
ولم تكشف وزاره الخارجيه عن الان عن يعني
حجم او عدد هؤلاء هؤلاء
في هذه اللحظه يجري التنسيق بين الحلفاء
لان حقيقه ليست هناك فرصه ثانيه
لاجلائهم في الوقت الحالي وبالتالي تم
التركيز على الدبلوماسيين بالدرجه الاولى
خصوصا وان هناك تهديدات يعني
بشانهم وايضا الموقع موقع هذه السفارات
بوسط الخرطوم يعني خاصه
والرصاص يعني يتشدد ويتناقل بين هذه
الاطراف وهذا سبب الذي ادى الى تاخير ربما
عمليه الاجلاء خاصه بالنسبه للبريطانيين
ولكن يعني
تواصل الحكومه البريطانيه يعني مصورتها
سواء مع الحلفاء المحليين او من خلال
الحلفاء الغربيين في محاوله
لوقف اعمال العنف وايضا يعني نقل رعايها
الى خارج السودان في هذا
مصطفى
بريطانيين ام نتحدث عن يعني متعاونين ايضا
من جنسيات اخرى
ما نعرفه حتى الان يعني وهم يعملون في
السفاره البريطانيه هم بريطانيون
دبلوماسيون افراد عائلاتهم لا ندري ما كان
هناك سودانيون يعني يعملون ولكن يعني
الاولويه كانت للفيطاني في الوقت الحاضر
والان سيتم التركيز على الرعايه
البريطانيه في السودان وخاصه وان كانت
هناك مناشده من قبل من قبلهم قالوا بان
الحكومه تركتهم في في خضم هذا الصراع لكن
جدد وزير الخارجيه يعني في وقت سابق من
اليوم
يتم التواصل مع هؤلاء وتسجيل يعني تسجيل
اسماءهم على الموقع الخارجيه للتاكد بمكان
وجودهم ونصحتهم ايضا بالبقاء في منازلهم
حتى تكون هناك فرصه بين فرصه بينما يتم
التنسيق مع الحلفاء لاجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب شكرا لك مصطفى زار ومراسل العربيه
حدثتنا من لندن
من القاهره اعود الى اللواء معتصم العجبه
المحلل العسكري وعضو تجمع قدامى المحاربين
السودانيين كيف تنظر يعني باختصار لو سمحت
لان الوقت ضيق عمليات الاجلاء تعني يعني
البعض ينظر اليها بانها معناها حرب طويله
الامد بين الطرفين كيف تنظر الى ذلك
عمليه الاجابه الصوره دي
بدي مؤشرات
وبدي مؤشرات انه
السفارات دي كلها طبعا عندها استخبارات
واجهزه امنيه وعلى تواصل
بانه يعني
التقارير الوصله
انه في
الفلات الامن ده حي طول امد
الحاجه الثانيه انه في منظمات ارهابيه
كانت خامده موجوده في السودان يعني في
تنظيم داعش موجود في السودان بوكو حرام
موجوده في السودان
باقي القاعده موجوده في السودان او فيها
جزء اسس في السودان يعني
في النظام البيع
على امن هؤلاء وهناك تخوف على طول امل
العمليه بتاعت حصلت دي العمليه بتاعت
الاجلاء حصلت دي بتاكد انه
الخلايا دي
احتمال كبير جدا
لانها حتنشق على كل حال بالنسبه للقتال
طبعا
حضرت اعتذر على المقاطعه ولكن انتهى الوقت
اللواء معتصم العجب المحلي العسكري وعضو
تجمع قدامه المحاربين السودانيين حدثنا من
القاهره
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات